you're looking at cape canaveral in
florida where boeing's starliner
spacecraft is on the launch pad set for
a crucial test this evening the
aerospace giant plans to send its
multi-billion dollar vehicle to the
international space station after a
series of delays chris van cleave is at
the kennedy space center chris good
morning what more can you tell us
well good morning starliner's already
experienced more than two years of
delays costing boeing around 600 million
dollars the aerospace giant is hoping
the third time will be the charm here a
successful mission could clear the way
for starliner to carry astronauts for
the first time and get boeing space
program back on track
for the third time boeing's starliner
has been rolled out to the launch pad
and hoisted atop a
172-foot tall atlas v rocket its mission
autonomously docked with the
international space station giving
boeing's reputation and place in the
space race a much needed boost we need
to go up fly the spacecraft without
humans on it demonstrate the automated
systems and come back safely in 2014
nasa gave boeing and spacex
dollar contracts to develop new
spacecraft that could fly american
astronauts to the iss ending the
dependence on russia
newcomer elon musk said spacex could do
it for 2.6 billion boeing the tried and
true aerospace juggernaut was awarded
4.2 billion ignition
while spacex soared launching five nasa
crews on its dragon spacecraft to the
iss since 2020 boeing starliner
stumbled and lift off the rise of
starliner this 2019 launch got starliner
into space but a software glitch
prevented its onboard engines from
firing on time and we do have an off
nominal insertion reported the
spacecraft failed to reach the iss
a second attempt last august was
scrubbed after tests at the launch pad
discovered 13 stuck valves in
starliner's propulsion system we think
we solved the problems so now the crew
we're no longer concerned astronaut mike
fink is training to be on starliner's
next mission what are you personally
watching for we're looking for the
technical side to to work as well as it
can if everything looks good we have a
nice smooth entry and landing then it
just builds up confidence and reduces
risk for the the next crew and where is
your level of confidence right now my
confidence is is really high there's the
unknown unknowns of course but
everything that we can do ahead of time
i think we've done
launch is currently set for about seven
o'clock local time this evening if all
goes well astronauts could hitch a ride
on starliner before the end of the year
if you're wondering why does nasa want a
capsule from spacex and boeing in space
redundancy is a good thing tony think
about it this way if you need to take
the kids to the doctor in your car
spacex has a flat tire wouldn't it be
great to be able to go into the garage
and hop into boeing
okay okay yeah
that's landed for me i appreciate it
good way to personalize it van cleef
thank you